this morning on the dish a chef who
danced her way to the top of her field
growing up in New York Claudia Fleming
wanted to be a ballet dancer and
followed that dream from childhood
through her mid-20s she supported
herself by working in restaurants and
when her dreams of dancing
professionally danced away she found new
inspiration in the kitchen she became a
pastry chef winning acclaim at New
York's prestigious Gramercy Tavern
including a James Beard Award and she
authored the last course a best-selling
award-winning as her cookbook that
became a classic of the genre and which
has just been re-released Claudia
Fleming good morning and welcome to the
day good morning thank you so much for
having me it is so good to see you
congratulations on the re-release I
think it really is a classic what do we
have in front of us here right now in
addition to the desserts and desserts
well if it were my preference we would
start with dessert but star would say
excellent okay
so here we have one of my signature
dishes which is a chocolate caramel tart
fashioned after a Rolo I love diving and
a cornmeal pancake with sabayon
and caramel blood oranges and we also
have a shaved fennel arugula and
radicchio salad
there are sweet potatoes roasted sweet
potatoes with balsamic glaze toasted
sesame seeds and parsley and garlic
roasted chicken and sheep's milk ricotta
toasts with roasted red peppers
prosciutto olive tapenade and spicy
honey that's amazing hari Prosecco
congrats again and a little clip Soho
it's so delicious and I mean you know
entire articles have been written about
this tart
it is unbelievable but everything in
that book when you think about a
rerelease of something that was in such
high demand and continues to be I know
it's it's wild I mean it's thrilling
it's so exciting to be able to revisit
all these things
to be able to introduce the last course
to a new generation
your first course was ballet my first
course was ballot how does one go from
ballet to pastries and desserts purely
by accident you know working in the in
the restaurant industry to support you
know my dance career for what it was I
just I gravitated to the kitchen and
jonathan waxman from jams which was
we're talking the 80s now gave me the
opportunity to come into the kitchen and
just explore to see if it was something
that I would enjoy doing full-time and
but it became it was several years
before I was able to really commit to
working in a kitchen what was it that
you loved about being in the kitchen the
pace and you know dancing is so much
about repetition mm-hmm
and the pursuit of perfection and
cooking is very much that way and it was
something that I was comfortable with
doing something repetitively it was
creative but only after you perfected
your technique but there's a lot of
people who love the kitchen and who love
being there and and and prepare and love
preparing food but they don't love
making desserts or baking or pastries
see what was it about that that
attracted you so much
I don't know the the autonomy in the
pastry Department is very different than
being on the line or interesting you get
to do things from the very beginning
until the very end you don't have prep
cooks in the pastry world whereas you do
on the savory side so I don't know you
everything was just from beginning to
end which is different than being on the
line I've read people have said that and
I may get this incorrect but that you're
a cook's pastry chef that you approach
that that's what you are do I approach
it primarily through flavor and texture
and balance and it's much less about
presentation I don't know I was trying
to create entrees on the dessert
you don't like cake yeah yeah mom that
can't possibly it's back cake
unbelievable
well pound cake is different from layer
cake because you see with the pancake I
can add the sabayon I can add the
caramel blood oranges I can add nuts I
can keep sort of layering it like an
entree whereas with a layer cake it's
one and done as you sign the disk win
and enjoy this meal
tell us you'd like to share it with well
okay
starting as a ballerina I eventually
worked my way into modern dance and I
would have to say I would love to have
dinner with Twyla Tharp oh yeah nice oh
yeah love it good one how about that I'm
still in the book by the way oh you
would Claudia Fleming we thank you and
if you like much for having me if you
like to know more about Claudia and the
dish head to our website at CBS this
morning
dot-com
you